[Musik]
trautes Heim in einer bürgerlichen
Vorortsiedlung von Padua Sarah Quinte
und Elisa babuan lieben ihre vier Kinder
vor zwei Monaten haben sie noch einmal
Nachwuchs bekommen in ihrer
gleichgeschlechtlichen Beziehung haben
Sie sich für künstliche Befruchtung
entschieden und Zwillinge zur Welt
gebracht innerhal der Gesellschaft
werden wir nicht diskriminiert wir sind
als Familie perfekt integriert die
Kinder gehen zur Schule und ihre
Klassenkameraden wissen ganz genau und
dass unsere Kinder zwei Mütter haben
aber wir spüren Druck von der Regierung
wir spüren den Druck einer Regierung die
uns diskriminiert die uns verfolgen will
die uns eine nach dem anderen sucht um
den Status zu
ändern aufgrund einer Direktive des
Innenministers aus Rom hatte die
Staatsanwaltschaft alle geburtsurkunden
von Kindern angefochten die in Familien
mit gleichgeschlechtlichen Eltern
geboren wurden nur die leibliche Mutter
solle dem nach anerkannt bleiben der
Partnerin wurde der Status entzogen
dabei wurden nicht nur die jüngsten
Geburtsurkunden in Frage gestellt
sondern alle bis ins Jahr 2017
annulliert wurden auch die Eintragungen
bei Kindern die jetzt 7 Jahre alt sind
dagegen haben auch Elisa und SAR geklagt
denn die Aberkennung des elternstatus
hat für Sie und Ihre Kinder
weitreichende
[Musik]
Folgen für uns bedeutet es Probleme zu
haben z.B um Elternzeit zu beantragen
oder auch wenn wir Urlaub im Ausland
machen wollen
ich kann z.B meinen Sohn nicht mitnehmen
wenn ich als Mutter nicht im
Reisedokument eingetragen bin und wenn
ich ihn von der Schule abholen will
bräuchte ich jedes Mal eine
Vollmacht seitdem die ultrarechte
Regierung in Rom an der Macht ist wird
gleichgeschlechtlichen Paaren das Leben
schwer gemacht in padoa whren sich
DemonstrantInnen seit Wochen gegen die
Diskriminierung
gleichgeschlechtlicher
wir geslechtern bestehen und nicht
aufgrund des Geschlechts der Eltern
gegründet werden viel mehr werden
Familien dort gegründet wo liebe
herrschtia Moni und ihre gleichgesinden
koalitionere haben dagegen von Anfang an
deutlich gemacht dass sie das ganz
anders sehen sie wollen dass wir Eltern
Teil 1 und Eltern Teil 2 statt Vater und
Mutter sagen das Geschlecht soll LGBT
sein der Bürger x aber wir sind keine
wir sind Menschen und wirerere
ich sage Mama und Papa weil Mama Mama
heißt und nicht geschlechtsneutral
Eltern 1 und 2 oder 32 oder sonst
was die Familie besteht aus Mama und
Papa und nicht aus anderen seltsamen
alchemien die uns jemand aufzwingen
möchte und dabei hat Italien ein
schweres demografisches Problem denn
Mama und Papa bekommen einfach nicht
genug Kinder bei der Geburten ist das
Land Schlusslicht in Europa melonis
Familienpolitik greife zu kurz sagt
einer der wichtigsten Demografen des
Landes kennzeichnend für Italien ist die
Diskrepanz zwischen der Zahl der
gewünschten Kinder und der Zahl der
realisierten Kinder und diese Kluft wird
von der Politik beeinflusst die dafür
sorgen müsste dass die Menschen ihre
Lebensentwürfe in vollem Umfang
verwirklichen
können wenig hat die Realität mit dem
Klischee in der Werbung zuun der heilen
Welt der italienischen Familie an das
auch die Regierung von gioria Meloni
anknüpft die Regierungschefin setzt auf
das klassische Familienbild obwohl sie
diesem selbst nicht entspricht da sie
vom Partner getrennt allein erziehend
ohne Trauschein lebt die Italienerinnen
nehmen es mit einer Mischung aus Spott
und
Fatalismus habt Kinder und bringt sie zu
Meloni wir müssen die Mentalität
ändern wir brauchen Hilfe und Sie werden
sehen dass wir Kinder
bekommen
wörtlich übersetzt scheißmütter nennen
sie sich weil sie dem klassischen
Rollenbild der italienischen Mama
zwischen Herd und Haushalt nicht
entsprechen die influenzerinnen Francesc
Fiore und SAR malr haben mit ihrem Blog
landesweit einen Nerv getroffen ihr
Bühnenprogramm ausverkauft melonis
ausgrenzende Familienpolitik wird hier
mit großer Skepsis
aufgenommen sie erfinden immer
wierderprme die nichts bewegen abgesehen
davonter
anderem
diese Unterstützung gilt außerdem
natürlich nur für traditionelle
Familien doch auch die sogenannten
traditionellen Familien kritisieren die
Familienpolitik melonis die Eltern des
zweijährigen achile in Rom haben sich
schweren Herzens gegen weitere Kinder
entschieden denn einerseits haben sie
sich ihren Kinderwunsch wegen
wirtschaftlicher Unsicherheiten erst
spät erfüllen können und andererseits
ist der wieder Einstieg in den Beruf
danach extrem
schwer wir würden es sehr gerne wir
würden sehr gerne ein zweites Kind haben
aber es ist nicht
möglich hier in Italien sagt man ein
Kind ist zu wenig zwei Kinder sind zu
viel denn aus organisatorischer
logistischer und auch wirtschaftlicher
Sicht wäre es
unhaltbar hätte es bereits staatliche
Anreize fürs erste Kind gegeben wäre das
zweite vielleicht längst unterwegs doch
allein für die private Kinderbetreuung
müssen Sie jeden Monat
bezahlen um den Negativtrend umzukehren
bräuchte es einen neuen
familienpolitischen
Ansatz der ideologische Ansatz
funktioniert in der Familienpolitik in
der Regel nicht was funktioniert ist ein
inklusiver Ansatz bei dem alle
Entscheidungen dazu beitragen dass ein
Kind in einem günstigen Umfeld
aufwachsen kann unabhängig ob sie
Italiener oder Migranten sind unabhängig
von der sozialen Schicht oder der
sexuellen
Orientierung S und Elisa haben trotz der
ungünstigen Bedingungen und der
Diskriminierung ihren Kinderwunsch
verwirklicht nun als ich mit den
Zwillingen schwanger wurde haben wir uns
gesagt dass die Regierung Meloni uns
eigentlich einen Preis verleihen sollte
weil wir ein perfektes Beispiel für eine
große Familie sind die die Regierung so
dringend möchte also sollten sie
eigentlich vorbeikommen und uns
persönlich einen Preis
überreichen doch darauf werden sie wohl
vergeblich warten es wäre ihnen ja schon
damit geholfen wenn die Diskriminierung
gleichgeschlechtlicher Paare in Italien
aufhören würde und in erster Linie die
Kinder im Mittelpunkt
stünden